and finally new rule Hollywood has to
remake Sophie's Choice but this time
it's about the current battle for the
Republican nomination and Sophie's
horrible choice isn't that she can't
save both her children it's that one of
them has to live
now I know that picking between Donald
Trump and Ted Cruz is driving
Republicans crazy Mitt Romney got so
angry today he punched the wall and
yelled Fudgsicle I almost feel bad for
Republicans although not really cuz they
did it to themselves Jesus you guys
started out with 17 candidates and
somehow you wound up with Mussolini and
Joe McCarthy in recent in recent weeks
Republicans have even been coming up to
me on the street or at a party or in an
airport restroom and and saying Bill
give me a hand
they say sure Trump and Cruz are both
despicable ass clowns but which one is
less awful glad you asked I say because
there always is a more correct choice
and I'm not just saying this to my
Republican friends I'm saying this to
liberals to Hillary Clinton is not a
sure thing you need a fallback beside
suicide in Canada
somebody's got to stay here and eat all
this kale so let's look at the
differences and there are real and
important ones between Cruz and Trump
they're not the same comparing them as
apples and orange Donald Trump is like
Ebola
he'll violently kill you right away Cruz
is more like the Zika virus we we won't
see the damage until future generation
Donald Trump wants to build a wall to
keep out creepy foreigners Ted Cruz is
proof we needed
Ted Cruz has a daughter who doesn't want
him to touch her
whereas Donald Trump's daughter is fine
with it
he he said it by the way he said it but
perhaps the most important difference
between the two men is this Donald Trump
is the most thin-skinned person in human
history and reacts to the smallest
slight with the hair trigger wounded ego
of a male flight attendant
whereas Ted Cruz is immune to insults
because he's learned to live in the
world where everyone everywhere has
always hated him laud villians used to
say they were born in a trunk
Ted was born stuffed in a locker like a
growing number of Republicans Lindsey
Graham publicly supports Cruz even as he
mentions that Ted makes his skin crawl
it's sort of like when they ask a gay
actor to kiss a woman they'll do it but
only because it's their job in fact it's
exactly like that
and and then there's Trump whose three
main endorsers are Sarah Palin Chris
Christie and Ben Carson or as I call
them caddy fatty and batty
so that's it Republicans I feel your
pain you're stuck between a rock and a
gross place the house of [ __ ] or the
house of douchebag team werewolf or team
vampire Verizon or AT&T but but we have
to accept that being a grown-up means
hard choices between disgusting options
you have to decide we all have to decide
so let me just say in the choice between
Trump and Cruz I for squarely choose Ted
Cruz
that's right my choice is Ted Cruz
because here's the deal breaker with
Donald Trump he's a lunatic if an on
rich or non-white person said the things
he says they wouldn't put him in the
White House they put him in Bellevue we
can't make a crazy we can't make a crazy
person commander-in-chief there are
actual job requirements it's not like
Mardi Gras parade King
do I think president Trump would
actually disappear people know but I
can't rule it out with him I can't rule
anything out what does he do on day one
send megyn kelly to Guantanamo Bay or me
he's already sued me the president signs
off on a kill list every day and sends
out the drones and I like going outside
so yes Ted Cruz will be our worst
president but Donald Trump might well be
our last which is why I say better dead
than Ted